So far, we've assumed that polynomials
are represented by their coefficients.
For example, A is equal to -x +
1x,+ 1x squared, for example.
If you've ever worked with polynomial
interpolation or fitting before,
however, you will know that an order n
polynomial is uniquely characterized by
its values at any n distinct points.
The order of a polynomial by the way
is the number of coefficients used to
define it or the degree plus one.
Hence we might just as well
represent a polynomial
by it's values at a sequence of
inputs as by it's coefficients.
For example, that same polynomial could
be represented by saying that A (-1)
= -2, A(0) = -2, and A(1) = 0.
Going from the coefficient
representation to the value
representation can be though
of as matrix multiplication.
To calculate A of some value, I take
the dot product of the corresponding
row of the matrix consisting of
the powers of the argument X
with this column consisting of
the coefficients of the polynomial a.
This matrix is important enough
that it gets its own name and
it's called the Vandermonde matrix.
Its determinant is the product of
the differences of all the values of x.
So as long as these are distinct
the determinant will be non-zero and
that means the matrix is invertible.
So given the values then, we should
be able to recover the coefficient.